it's great to welcome Euron brook to the
program today Iran is the chairman of
the ein Rand Institute and host of the
yeren Brook show this is the first in a
series of discussions that we're
producing in partnership with the ein
Rand Institute we're going to be talking
eventually about capitalism about
welfare programs about a maybe universal
basic income and more today we are going
to start by talking about Iran herself
and her ideas Iran so great to have you
on oh happy to be here thanks for having
me on so in in my audience I don't think
it will come as a shock to my audience
to hear that my sort of world view
overall is not particularly in line with
objectivism and Iran's ideas as I
understand them but it's possible of
course that I that I misunderstand them
to some degree so just to like get
started from your perspective how do you
if someone says I've never heard of iron
Rand I don't know what objectivism is
what's the entry point to starting a
conversation about that well first I
would note she was a very successful
author she a Russian a Russian immigrant
somebody who came to this country very
young with nothing she started out
literally with nothing came to Hollywood
to try to get a job and and worked in
the back lot as an extra solder as an
extra worked in the wardrobe department
learned English in order to be able to
write write scripts to Hollywood and
ultimately write novels and became you
know one of the most successful American
authors ever I mean whether you agree
with her or not
Fountainhead and Atlas Shrugged have
sold millions and millions of copies and
given given that the thickness of the
book it's a pretty amazing story they
sell probably more today than they did
when she was alive so she was a very
very successful author and you know she
developed a philosophy to large extent
you know that the silver literature the
philosophy was there in order to help
her define and describe what she called
the ideal man ideal man a woman that the
ideal human being
and her philosophy is she called it a
philosophy for living on earth for
living life here now on this planet and
it was really trying to project or did
project heroically of man so she had a
very heroic view of what we as
individuals are capable of so that would
be an introduction and then you know I'd
love to be able to go kind of into an
overview of what her philosophy really
stands for yeah and I think you know I
having having read it's been a while but
I read The Fountainhead it I read a lot
and a lot of literature it was not my
cup of tea politics aside but we are not
here to adjudicate a literary critique
here but but I I think that your point
about the philosophy serves the writing
is an interesting one because I think
you would probably agree much of the
popularization of the fiction writing
today is from groups that are actually
really more into the the political
philosophy of iron Rand than the fiction
and and in that sense it's maybe a good
entry point into what the philosophy is
yes I think most people most people
using the literature in order to get
some way but that was not her goal her
goal was not particularly when she was
young was not I want to change the world
or I want to present a particular
philosophy that will therefore write
literature right for a very young age
wanted to write literature and then she
came to a point where she wanted to
project a particular type of human being
how would you know how to walk in in The
Fountainhead and she said well what is
the what is the views out there in the
world of what this kind of human being
looks like what is an ideal man based on
the philosophies that acceptable in
society and she looked out day and she
studied and she she read a lot of
philosophy and she said none of these
are mean
none of these are what I want to present
none of them are what I sense is is the
ideal man I therefore I need to do some
thinking some studying and to develop a
philosophical view of what that looks
like so
so she develops the philosophy again in
service of the literature so if we start
with the metaphysics I'm and really
unread views the world as reality is
what it is it's not what Mia you feel
like it should be it's not why son what
some of the consciousness God or some
other mystical element thinks it should
be it is what it is it's to quote
Aristotle a is a it's unbeautiful and
then how do we know reality well here
again we know reality through our reason
through our senses our sense as a valid
a senses actually give us information
about reality as it is and it is a
reason that gives us information about
reality so emotions are not tools of
cognition and neither's revelation there
is no such thing as mystical revelation
truth needs to be ascertained through
reason and reason alone and here I think
maybe you know your audience might you
know at this point at least up to this
point think okay it's an extent that
their secular they might think that that
this is something that they they agree
with and I think this is a good
foundation or which we can build maybe
whatever they would ever agreement they
might be but then the question is who
reasons right and the fact is that only
individuals can reason just like we we
don't have a collective stomach and we
can't eat for each other we don't have a
collective brain there's no such thing
as a collective consciousness
there's no floating consciousness above
us all that reasons that discovers the
truth only individuals can use their
reason to discover the truth for
themselves and in morality it's only our
individual life that is the the starting
point for any kind of for any kind of
meaning so it's our individual life that
we must attain so morality is based on
the idea that our focus and morality
should be on own survival and that our
moral purpose in life is our own
individual happiness so it's not a
morality of we should sacrifice it's not
a morality
it's a morality that rejects the idea
that your life is in service to the
group service to other people or service
to a god your life the purpose of your
life is a service of your own survival
and the purpose of it all is your own
happiness but it also rejects the idea
that we should ask other people to
sacrifice for us that is it rejects the
idea of exploiting other people of using
other people in order to achieve our
happiness our happiness as our
responsibility and we must earn it
so let's let's I mean that's a lot there
so let's start digging into where if we
go a little further we might start to
get to some points of disagreement so
the idea of you know a reality
independent of consciousness so to speak
yes that is not unique to objectivism so
while it will likely sound relatively
inoffensive to many in my audience and
even something that they generally would
would agree with it's important I think
to understand that it is not unique to
objectivism and when we talk about
something like a reason as an example
the idea of reason I think is very
appealing to the vast majority of my
audience the issue I think from some in
my audience and for me is that when you
look at the epistemology of Objectivism
you start getting into things like to
pick an example existence is identity
which for me at least starts to border a
little bit on the Deepak Chopra type of
stuff you know cosmic consciousness and
all of these things that they sort of
sound like they make sense but at the
same time does this really mean anything
objectively so Iran actually never says
existence as identity you're conflating
two different things that she says okay
she says existence exists it just exists
independent of consciousness and then
she says things are what they are a is a
you a cannot be B it cannot be it's
contradiction things are just all what
they are so yes there's a sense in which
this is not original this very much a
sense where this is
Aristotle and she she thinks up
basically three fundamental core
axiomatic ideas at the core of
metaphysics and that is the existence
exists the law of identity there is the
Chilean law of identity of a si and the
law of causality things act based on
their own nature I don't think that's
very controversial to secular you know
secular philosophers certainly to
philosophers who believe in reality
which is not everybody they're a bunch
of philosophers out there who don't
think reality is a is a stable thing and
they don't they even if they believe
it's independent consciousness they
don't believe it's it they believe in
contradictions Hegel would be an example
that things are you know there are
contradictions in reality in and of
itself so so while I think she he or she
is very much mister Tilian I do think
the way she puts it all together is
uniquely hers but I don't think this is
where you get into controversy I do
think there's some issues in
epistemology which could and and are
more controversial and and in where
there is more probably more conflict
between her and other philosophers and
and where I think she's more original
now we're not gonna get very deep into
this because among other things it's not
my area of expertise but you know for
example in Manoa Conte has a very
different view of human reason human
reason to a large extent for Kant is
detached from what we'll call real
reality right it's it human reason in a
sense creates its own reality because it
is a it is there's a filter between the
real world out there that we never know
that we never will know and what our
conception of the world is and that
reason is more played inside your own
mind and at the end of the day he leads
us towards a philosophy of the primacy
of consciousness where consciousness is
primary not reality his view of reason
detaches us from actual reality from
actual facts from from from truth in my
view and I think that's why Randy viewed
Cantus as is the most damaging
of all philosophers out there in terms
of in terms of the Enlightenment
movement towards a proper understanding
of Reason amano accounts have throws a
wrench into it and blows us into a
completely different direction I think
for sure one of the most controversial
general areas is the way in which this
worldview would dictate politics be done
today which is in a sense very relevant
to many in the audience who say well
hold on if I adopt a Randian worldview
what does that mean about how government
should function etc but before we get to
that there's one thing you only get long
before we get to that yes um the one
thing I did want to mention is there is
there a sort of existentialism issed
idea that goes through some of this and
specifically what i mean by that is the
idea from existentialism that what is
important that it is an achievement
merely to live one's life and to sort of
be that that is in and of itself
something to consider an achievement
am i wrong to feel that there is some
something about that through Iran's
philosophy it is but but she is very
different than the exist Angeles in this
sense yes so there is a an in you know
before we get to politics I think
probably where there's real controversy
I think with with the audience and
probably with you is inner ethics and
and I think that's where we should spend
some time but this is related so for the
exist any list is this the achievement
is just to survive and it doesn't matter
so much how you survive and indeed
happiness is really fleeting and almost
any possibility for them for and
survival is an achievement but it's not
just any survival it's not survival at
the material level it's survival what
she considers survival qua human being
survival as a full functioning human
being as a as a fully manifest human
being so it's survival to your fullest
potential
that's what to her is the moral ideal
it's the Thrive in every dimension of
our lives it's to make the most of the
life that we have and again in in in
opposition if you will to the exist
Angelus who are very driven by emotional
considerations and-and-and by you know
even to differentiate her from Nietzsche
where there is this power of will which
again is emotion Rand believes that the
way to achieve success in living as a
human being is to commit oneself to
reason to commit oneself to rationality
to commit myself to facts to be you know
excruciating the honest about everything
and committed to to the facts of reality
and everything one does and to focus one
lives on living the best life one can
for oneself but guided by reason about
emotion not by something called the will
but by guided by one's own reason and
one's own one's understanding of what is
true and of the facts of reality yeah I
mean I think where we where we start to
run into a problem and I've had these
discussions before with people who
subscribe to any ideology doesn't matter
what it is is that when you lay out the
principles in the abstract the way you
and I are doing right now it seems much
more tidy and neat than when you
actually have to solve problems in the
real world and when the principles that
one would espouse for themselves come
into conflict with someone else
attempting to live those same principles
and it seems like that is where the real
hard work is and if we want to use this
to lead into the ethics that's fine or
we can stay here but the principles are
a great starting point but I feel like
there are only 20% of the conversation
and the 80% I believe is done in
figuring out how this applies in the
real world
oh no doubts I mean everybody has to
first understand the principles and
accept them will not accept them but
first you have to understand them
and then one has to apply them and an
application is not easy it's it's not
trivial I think you know it's it's about
living and it's about living consistent
with those principles and what does it
mean therefore to live one's life for
one's self guided by reason well for
Rand it means certain virtues it means
committing ourselves to certain virtues
it it's committing one selves to one's
mind committing ourselves to
national rationally thinking through not
acting on emotions and a lot of that is
not it's not only in conflict with other
people I mean we we have plenty of
situations in life where our mind tells
us to do one thing and I emotions are
guiding us in a different direction and
we need guidance in order to decide
should I follow my emotion or should I
follow my reason and it's not obvious
say you know the Deepak Chopra's of the
world will often tell you follow your
emotion you know follow your so-called
intuition and Rand says no in any
decision you must use your mind you must
think it through you must follow the
facts and and and reason so it's not
just with other people but suddenly when
it comes to other people there's a
question of justice which then is an
application of this morality how do you
how should you treat other people and
Rand would argue should treat them in
justice and what does that mean you
should treat them based on how they
deserve to be treated and in different
contexts in one life deserts means
different things so already there are
certain Marcos that would say you should
treat people the same that you know the
justice requires equality and Rand
rejects that when views justice as an
issue of desert and we could go over
every one of her virtues she has seven
which he articulates every one of those
virtues and each one of those applies
reason and rationale to a certain aspect
of one's life with the goal being living
the best life that you can with a goal
being your own individual happiness yeah
I mean I guess to put in the most
straightforward way the way in which
this creates an obvious conflict is that
person a living their best life may
require or at least it may be most
readily achieved via actions that
prevent person B from living their best
life as just equally and and
definitively defined by Randi and
philosophy and how does how do we
account for that so
Rand has a whole essay on this and
and you know she has an essay uh which
that's the question answers the question
is there a conflict between rational man
a rational Malley and constant conflict
are they values in constant conflict and
overview is know that there is no
conflict there and you would have to
come up with with particular you know
particular scenarios in order to kind of
untangle all that but she could argue
that my seeking my values does not
conflict with your seeking your values
in the big scheme of things now in the
moment it might appear for that to be
that so for example only one of us can
get the job right there's a job where
both were both were both applying for it
were both rational but both being honest
were both qualified but only one of us
is going to get the job and she would
argue that a rational person would not
want a job if somebody else was more
qualified for him for whatever reason
then he was he would not want the job if
he was getting some special favor
or if he was being viewed as yeah you're
less qualified but we'll take you that
is it's not a value to that person to
get a job under those circumstances and
therefore it is consistent with his own
values sometimes not to get a job so it
might be hard it might in the moment the
unpleasant but in the scope of one's
life it is not a contradiction I don't
know I mean this this starts to get
edging into there's an interesting clip
it's not a perfect analogy but there's a
very interesting discussion that took
place between Jordan Peterson and a guy
named Matt Dillahunty and in a
discussion about morality absent of
religious doctrine Jordan Peterson
asserted that even those who believe
that they are atheists if they are moral
deep down they actually are religious
they may just not even know and when you
say that even if in the short term it
appears as though this is a violation of
the values because they wanted the job
even if they were less qualified that in
the long run it is more consistent with
one's values not to get the job even if
it means your family starves even if it
means all sorts I mean
you know it's you know borderline
borderline conditions are always tricky
and kind of like bored scenarios
I don't believe a part of morality most
of us will apply for jobs are not in the
situation where your family starves it's
one job out of many but but I think I
think it's absolutely real I I think
that you know lots of people get jobs
which way they are not qualified for and
they feel terrible once they discover
that they're not qualified for and the
long-term negative consequences on their
lives are not good and they'd be better
off if they didn't get the job in the
long run there are a lot of you can you
can imagine and and I think it's it's
self-evident that a lot of situations
where we want something but actually not
getting that something at that moment in
time is actually better for us now if
you might not realize it at the time
we're all gonna be disappointed well are
gonna be sad sometimes life is not one
long you know you know chewy happy an
unquestioning you know pleasure
pleasurable thing their ups and downs
and their challenges but the point is
that if one lives consistently according
to these ideas one does achieve a state
of happiness one does achieve success
and when one reviews one's life when you
look at these situations I think if you
approach it rationally you don't feel
like oh there's this I hate this other
guy because he got the job at I didn't I
you know if if I think that the decision
was made grassley then he got the job at
I didn't I don't know I I think that I
think that it's a bit dismissive of the
reality that you know in the scenario
where the two people vying for the job
are middle-class people who if they
don't get this job they'll find some
other job I think it is very sort of
establishment centric in the sense that
there are hundreds of millions or even
billions of people on this planet for
whom it really might be the opportunity
that exists to feed their family and to
avoid absolutely horrible conditions and
the idea of saying listen in the long
run just adhering to the values is going
to be better for everybody for a lot of
people it's not getting the job even if
you're unqualified
is actually going to be better
objectively yes I know but look I am
assuming here that people are rational
I'm assuming people here a living and
thinking long term and yes there are
situations in life where you you grab
what you can get certainly as the
countries in the world right now where
people are starving where I don't expect
them to have this kind of attitude and
and they are living a lifeboat scenario
they're living survival you know get the
job or die and then you grab the job I
mean I'm not gonna judge somebody like
that in in that kind of scenario I'm
just saying that and and I don't
consider this middle class because I
consider I consider this true in in any
free economy that this is true of
anybody in whatever their social
economic status is that in a free
economy if you know you're never on the
verge of starvation and advance free
economy you never on the verge of
starvation options exist and and maybe
this now spills into economics and
spills into politics but you've got to
take over if you want to have a healthy
successful life if you're gonna be happy
long term you're gonna have to take that
long term perspective and again that
long term perspective might be painful
in the short run but it'll pay off they
pay off multiple times in the long run
and this is not just look I'm trying to
think of a scenario but you know you
leave me without a specific one I mean I
think this is an example of why some
people hear this and they say wow that
sounds extraordinarily dismissive of a
lot of people's situations it sounds
like and this is I don't know if you
would agree that Randy and philosophy
feeds into applied to modern politics a
sort of libertarian ideology I don't
like it would libertarian but
free-market ideology certainly firstly
feeds into free markets and look let's
let's take let's take a political issue
for the hell of it yeah and let's take
something like affirmative action right
so a certain percentage of people get a
jobs now because they qualified but
cause of the color of their skin which I
find offensive in a second I think that
that we need we can't go further until
we don't necessarily agree about what
that if you have met you've identified
people can be equally qualified you
could have equally qualified people
where deference is given to a group that
has been historically oppressed
that's hypothetically possible let's
make an assumption I'm okay it's true
always okay certainly is not true always
sometimes the person with a different
color of the skin is better sometimes
they're the same but let's say there are
circumstances and I believe there are
circumstances and I think the empirical
evidence suggests once in a while
somebody gets in for a job they're not
fully qualified for there were more
people who are more qualified for and
they get the job in spite of that yeah I
would argue the primary reason for that
is nepotism not affirmative action but
fair whatever the reason may be there's
certainly a cases where it's affirmative
action and and and you can just look at
the admission standards at Harvard to
see that in action but what does that
say to them put aside the political
issue let's talk just about the person
what does that reflect about in terms of
their own self-esteem and it seems to
diplay that they have in getting that
job well first it they don't know why
they got the job and there's a there's a
probability it might be very low you
know maybe I'll accept what you say and
it's very low but there might be a
probability that they didn't get the job
because of the qualification maybe it's
because of a nepotism
maybe it's affirmative action maybe it's
a thousand different other things but it
effects their self-esteem okay you don't
know why they got the job it reduces the
ability to have pride in what they
achieve in that job when they fail in
that job if they fail or in the school
if they fail that is crushing to them
right so I think it has real-world
application and I'm against nepotism I'm
against people getting what they don't
deserve what they don't deserve on the
merits and it when people do get it it
has a psychological self-esteem price to
pay and I would rather live in a world
in which we minimize that you're never
going to minimize you know
nepotism completely but I would like to
minimize it as much as possible and I
think the only way to minimize it is to
for both parties all parties to adopt a
rational approach to hiring for example
or to any activity in life and look we
don't live in a rational world we don't
live in which people for the most part
rational and put aside the politics put
aside the particular politics even in in
personal ethics people are not rational
people are not honest people are
deceiving themselves and lying to
themselves all the time and people are
committing a following emotions and and
following lots of things that I think
are wrong so it doesn't surprise me the
people upset by lots of stuff that
happens to them all around them and the
fact that I know that the higher that
people are hiring might not be basing
the hiring on the most rational merit
based assessment that they might be
nepotism let's say or other standards
going into would cause me to be
frustrated if I don't get a job yeah I
mean let's say III not going to now
adjudicate affirmative action in total
because we've got so many other things
to talk about but I think this is sort
of like when the focus around the
climate becomes should the government
force you to use a particular type of
straw I argue that's the wrong
conversation when a hundred companies do
70% of the pollution me changing the
type of straw I use I think is a red
herring in the same way when you look at
something like college admissions at the
at the really elite schools and you look
at the number of people that are either
legacy admissions related to someone
who's made a big donation episode and
you compare it to cases in which what
you've got equally qualified people
where deference was given to someone
from an underprivileged group I focus on
the bulk of the problem myself but
that's probably a nama conversation I
mean again my focus is completely
different yes you know III would love
for Harvard to be a truly private
institution that does not get a dime
from the government and as a consequence
makes its own admissions decisions and
if it wants to discriminate in any way
it has the right to discriminate so what
I want is for the government what I
ideally want with all these issues is to
the government to get out of the way in
private citizens
engage in it and and maybe later we'll
get to the pollution question and what
counts as pollution what doesn't and and
and how you deal with real pollution
issues but but you know I think that
once we once we acknowledge that once we
let private individuals do what they
want to do rather than have to abide by
some government regulation or some
government standard they then you have
to adjudicate by who should be
discriminated against who is it Asians
as it whites is it and and then we we
get into a conversation that's all
racist because we're judging people by
they race one way or the other whether
it's whether it's or treat Asians or the
retreat whites or the way we treat
blacks or anybody else I think that's a
losing proposition to begin with we you
know we they in in and this is this is a
really bad place to be and it's a bad
place the country isn't but going back
to personal morality yeah the key here
is for people to take their life
seriously and look there's nothing in
this philosophy that is middle class or
elitist in any way I truly believe that
these are the set of ideas these a set
of virtues that apply to anybody anybody
starting out in any position in life if
they want to have a good life and a good
life is not measured in money you know
so it's not about money it's not a it's
not just about money when he's a factor
but it's not just about money that's
another I mean people always think about
Manny materialistic terms but it's not
just about money it's about the kind of
life you live and to live a good life a
life of pride and self esteem a life
that you can be proud of having lived
requires you know following certain
principles and it's not always easy to
follow those principles the decisions
don't always gonna make you happy I give
you a giving an example from The
Fountainhead which which you said you
have read I don't know if you remember
the scene or not but there's a scene on
The Fountainhead how it work is the
struggling architect and there's a scene
in The Fountainhead
where this bank is gonna hire him to
build a building and they get a pay him
a lot of money but they just want to
make few changes to his design and a few
changes to his design completely destroy
the integrity of the building
integrity of a design and he says no and
he walks away and he lands up working in
a quarry in order to feed himself
because yeah sometimes your decisions
are very tough now is he better off for
making that decision long term not
taking the money and going to work in
the quarry Iran's point is yes your
personal integrity living by those ideas
and sticking to that integrity and
living a complete life without
compromise sometimes it's gonna require
to go work in a quarry sometimes it's
gonna require you to somehow lose a lot
of money and struggle but if you follow
through on it you will be successful in
living whether it comes in dollar signs
or not you will be successful in life
and that is why they call it a fictional
novel you see people who do that it
happens but the opposite happens as well
as the reality I mean there are many
cases we a compromise on the building I
compromise our value a nice to live
happy life the opposite would be the
opposite would be in the short turn in
the short term you compromise that
compromise allows you in the long term
to take the fruits of that compromise
and change the system that is what the
problem is I mean listen this is like
I'll give you an example and then maybe
this will be a good we're getting into
the politics so it may be a good place
to pause I often have to make decisions
about listen air travel would you grant
that air travel does pollute the planet
we can disagree about what the solution
would be or how much but planes flying
around this this releases emissions into
the atmosphere would you would you grant
that you're on I grant that it releases
emissions it's a very good one could
argue I should stop all air travel to
places where I am going to speak about
what I do but I could also say listen
the cost that I am exhibiting by
releasing this is smaller than the
number of people I might inspire who in
the next 50 years will go and make
positive changes that that is how I
might compromise my value in the short
term but in the long term
I actually am doing a
thing well I mean you know if you really
accept what you believe and and if let's
let's say we'll accept a extreme version
of that where the world is literally you
know it's it's in the next 12 years we
don't stop flying x12 the world the
world is gonna end then I'm not sure
that's a good compromise I don't buy
into that I'm not sure you do but but
yes what has to what has to have a
hierarchy of values and figure out how
to ascertain how to gain our most
important values and sometimes one has
to give up a lower value in order to
attain a higher value and that's you
know what Iran is arguing is for
creating a hierarchy of value defining a
hierarchy of value and making sure you
never give up high value your integrity
as an artist okay or low value that
would be a sacrifice but giving up a
lower value for the sake of a higher
value well of course you do that every
day every minute that you live is a
minute you can do 55 different things
and you choose to do one and in a sense
you're giving up doing the 54 other
things but you're not so the the idea
here is is to have principles by which
one defines one's values one creates a
hierarchy of value and then one makes
sure that you're never sacrificing
something higher for something lower
okay one's life consistently based on
that all right well we've now expanded
to just beyond the initial definition
which was just about any compromise to
the idea of a hierarchy which i think is
a more well-developed idea sure I mean I
I you know this is a very short period
of time but we're talking about you know
when I said compromise I mean a model
comprised obviously if my wife wants to
go to movies and I want to go to
restaurant and we call and I compromise
and go to movies with her that's not a
model compromise that we're gonna you
know that that I believe you should
never do so it's it's a question of how
important is something to you absolutely
a key and one should never give work
what's really really important for
something less important so let's pause
the conversation there in part two we're
really getting into economics and
politics and in part two we're going to
be dealing with capitalism specifically
we've been speaking with Iran bro
who is chairman of the ein Rand
Institute and host of the yeren Brook
show and we will have our next
conversation with Iran coming up very
soon